one of our next guests is one of the
biggest social media stars on the planet
she rose to fame in 2019 on tick-tock
and now has more than
85
million followers that's just crazy
[Applause]
i mean
i was really excited to have a
conversation with her because she has
the ear and eyes of so many people
so this is our conversation with addison
ray take a look
hi
like
where did you get the confidence to put
yourself out there and have that wink
and a smile
um i guess like growing up my mom and my
family have always been like just like
really uplifting and kind and always
like wanting me to express myself in all
the ways i could and i grew up in
dancing which i always loved because i
like in if you danced ever or cheered
it's like ah facial and we like say a e
i o u and i'm like all right i've kept
that forever now because i always do
facial expressions like just to kind of
give it like that extra you know emotion
especially in photos and stuff so thank
you but just like confidence wise yeah
like always um being influenced by
people around me that were just really
positive and um and like always brought
out the best of me i guess um i mean
okay so you have 85 million followers do
you go with authenticity and mood today
is a dance day
do sometimes you wake up and go okay
today's more introspective i i have
things to think about and learn and
explore with everybody how do you gauge
it
um
i honestly just kind of follow my gut i
think there are days when i'm like all
right today is a dance day like i'm
gonna learn a dance and i'm gonna make
it good and then my mom also too will be
like all right let's make let's do a
dance today so like the other day i was
teaching her dance and then other days
i'm like okay how can i like learn more
and like
understand more about other people in
the world around me but i mean it really
just depends i kind of follow my gut and
just do whatever makes me feel good
which is kind of been my my thing this
year i'm like all right what can make
you feel the best and also like make
people feel the best around you too
okay well you're a beauty maven i heard
you have three tips and i'm literally
ever since i heard that been like what
are the three tips tell me now teach me
okay so for me
um i'd probably say like one a big one
that i always do is like i love matching
my lipstick to my blush so i'll like use
my lipstick as blush looks like yes okay
thank god i'm not the only one some
people look at me like i'm crazy when i
do that but i'll use my lipstick as a
blush that's number one for me i've
always done that i think it's just so
good to like also have like a
monochromatic look so i'll use like even
my lipstick on my eyes sometimes like
just in the crease i don't know weird
but i think it looks cute and then i
love using like an eyebrow pencil as
freckles because it kind of like gives
that like faded ish but also like ties
together the look in a way which i love
and then
i found this facial steamer that i
actually like live and read by and it's
like almost like being in a steam room
but it's just like a portable facial
steamer and i like use it all the time
and i just like sit in front of it with
the mask on
and then just breathe in like this
humidity like humidity and i'm from the
south so i love humidity love like the
misty feeling and it cleans my face out
so good and that's like one thing that
i'm like everyone should definitely have
a facial steamer in their life because
if you don't know a facial steamer meet
her immediately
um okay now
i'm so excited about your new fragrance
line um the af collection by addison ray
and you have three cents
um
let's call them vibes um of chill happy
and hyped mm-hmm
they're like
super fun bottles that like change
colors so they're like
work with your mood and there's like a
science-backed um process that we went
through to like really
make these sense like trigger different
feelings you have so like chill can make
you more relaxed
happy can make you you know just in a
better mood and then hyped is like
energy and they also change colors with
heat and they're like
i'll try to rub my hands together um but
this one
this one's yellow one there we go oh my
god this one's yellow i know so once you
get it like super warm they change
colors so it's like a mood ring which is
like super fun and like
reminiscent of like you know when i was
born which is two thousand so like early
2000s mood rings things like that and
they change color so it's really fun an
interactive experience
yeah
i love them
be sure to check out addison's new
fragrance line on
addisonrayfragrance.com
thank you addison
and by the way addison and i are going
to do some fun stuff on social she is
posing a really fun question to me so
check out the drewbarmershow.com and our
youtube channel and all of our digital
platforms because me and addison ray are
gonna play
[Music]